Joe Biden's allies come out of the
woodwork to stop Bernie Trump fulminates
over the anti Bernie coupe and Chris
Matthews is gone I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show the bench Bureau
show is sponsored by expressvpn surf the
web with peace of mind sign up right now
do it now and expressvpn comm slash man
well don't worry we will get to Chris
Matthews leaving and instead we say
gotta be I'm very sad about it gotta
admit to you I'm better website yeah cuz
Matthews go he's gone go when we get to
that in a little bit very percent about
it one of my favorite impersonations
finally retired done a better place I'll
see you in heaven old friend well get to
Christmas in the programs you lasted 23
years until the woke scolds got him and
that really is what happened but we'll
get to that in a little bit we begin at
this hour with the great consolidation
that's what's happening inside the
Democratic Party so I will say this
Democratic Party is way way more
systematic than the Republican Party was
in 2016 so remember in 2016 yet a
fragmented field when he had Donald
Trump he was running straight for the
nomination you had like eight candidates
and none of them would get out Marco
Rubio wouldn't get out in favor of Cruz
Cruz wouldn't get out in favor of Rubio
John Kasich for some reason was just
like I'm gonna stand for no reason ever
just a Raisin in the Sun John Kasich
piece of paper wadded up in your pocket
that went through the washing machine
attitude was just going to stay in the
race all the way to the end and he did
and he ended up being president
no he just stated well the Democratic
Party doesn't have the same problem
there there at least systematic enough
to say to the also-rans guys you need to
get out and that's pretty much what
happened yesterday people who judge got
out Amy Klobuchar got out and not only
did they get out then when they endorsed
Biden because it is very obvious that
this race is now a Biden Sanders race
now Michael Bloomberg is still sitting
out there similar just throwing wads of
cash like a rapper at a strip club I
mean just take it just boom making it
rain everywhere no one understands why
no one understands what he's doing but
he continues to do that but Bloomberg is
really not a threat my prediction for
tonight tonight is Super Tuesday my
prediction for tonight
Biden over performs the polls Bloomberg
wildly under performs the polls because
as I said yesterday my going theory
about Michael Bloomberg is that he was a
placeholder for the anti Bernie
sentiment that if you felt that Biden
was not a durable candidate you said in
holls that you were gonna vote for
Bloomberg but now the Biden looks more
durable a lot of those votes are gonna
fall away from Bloomberg and back toward
Biden now that it's become a two-person
race basically that means the Bloomberg
is not gonna cross that 15 percent
threshold that you are required to pass
in order to receive delegates in all of
these states and that means that those
delegates instead are gonna be split
among the other candidates which means
more victories for Joe Biden so I think
the Biden is gonna over perform tonight
it would actually not be the world's
largest shock if Joe Biden were to end
up outperforming Bernie Sanders tonight
and the betting markets are reflecting
this the betting markets are now
reflecting that at the very least what
you're going to see on Super Tuesday is
a delegate split that it's not gonna be
a Bernie runaway that Bernie made you
real well in California but that as long
as Joe Biden passes 15 percent in
California and splits the vote at all he
is likely to emerge within a hundred
delegates of Bernie Sanders and if that
happens and if it's a neck-and-neck race
there are a lot of big states coming up
like Florida like Georgia where Biden
can really run up the score on Bernie
make up that deficit and end up in a
position to win a plurality of the votes
now that doesn't mean that Biden is
gonna end up winning the Democratic
nomination outright on the first ballot
right now 538 has rejiggered all of
their calculations here the 538
calculations 61% chance then nobody has
a majority of the delegates then nobody
hasn't so a 2 in 3 3 & 5 chance that
nobody is gonna have a majority of the
delegates which technically is not an
open convention but it's a contested
convention because nobody wins outright
in second place is Joe Biden now so
Biden has well surpassed Bernie Sanders
Sanders has dropped precipitously in the
538 estimate of delegates Biden now has
a 31% shot at winning a majority of the
delegates Sanders is all the way down at
8% and if you look at the number of
delegates they are forecasting before
Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders and Michael
Bloomberg
they've got Bloomberg dropping and
they've got Biden precipitously rising
to 717 hundred and 38 delegates he needs
2000 to just win this thing but 1738
delegate Sanders all the way down at 13
63 so that consolidation of the field is
happening at exactly the right time for
Joe Biden and again this shows
discipline within the party I mean you
do have to admire it as a Republican the
discipline within the party now part of
that has to do with the fact that there
is more time in the Democratic calendar
to mobilize that opposition the
Republican Party doesn't have as much
time if somebody starts running up
victories very early
on in Republican primaries because they
are winner-take-all it is difficult to
stop them imagine that Iowa had been
winner-take-all and mate like let's
assume that the Bernie had won Iowa he
actually didn't boot a judge won Iowa
but let's assume for a second that
Bernie won Iowa outright let's assume he
won New Hampshire outright let's assume
we want Nevada outright and suddenly
he's racking up these winner-take-all
scores and let's assume California we're
not a plurality and we're not it we're
not proportional delegations instead it
were just a winner-take-all state well
then Sanders would be in a much more
commanding position that was the
position that Trump was in Trump was
winning thirty five percent of the vote
and walking away with a hundred percent
of the delegates that created this giant
eight ball that nobody could get out
from behind inside the Republican Party
for the Democrats there's a little bit
more lead time and that means there is
time to mobilize opposition one state
victory in South Carolina has now put
Joe Biden on a fairly solid path toward
the nomination and that became even
clearer with all these other candidates
dropping out so Peabody Judge didn't
need really to be urged my Peabody judge
understood fairly clearly that his
future runs through Joe Biden will get
to pee Buddha judge dropping out of the
race in just one second first let's talk
about HR issues so you're running a
company you don't really think a lot
about HR forgot a small business let me
tell you as our business has grown HR
issues become more and more of an issue
HR can absolutely kill you if you don't
have proper compliance if you have not
actually done all you can to make sure
that your HR department is excellent HR
issues can kill you in cases of wrongful
termination suits or minimum wage
requirements or labor regulations you
need an HR department but here's the
problem an HR manager salary is not
cheap it can cost you like 70 grand a
year so let's say you're a small company
you don't wanna hire a full-time HR
manager this is why you need Bambi's buh
ba MB EE was created specifically for
small business you can get a dedicated
HR manager who will craft HR policy and
maintain your compliance all for just 99
bucks a month which is a fantastic deal
I mean saves you a ton of money your
dedicated HR manager is available by
phone email real-time chat it's not
somebody who's in India picking up the
phone it is an American with HR training
who is going to be able to help you out
from on boarding determinations they
customize your policies to fit your
business and help you manage your
employees day to day all for just 99
bucks a month its month-to-month there
are no hidden fees you can cancel any
times if you're unsatisfied all you've
lost is 99 bucks you didn't start your
business because you wanted to spend
time on HR compliance let Bambi help get
your free HR audits today you can't
afford to get HR
you get it wrong can cost you literally
millions of dollars go to Bambi calm
slash up hero right now to schedule your
free HR audit that's BA MBE EECOM slash
up hero again BAM to the BAE comm slash
apparel Bambi comm Shapiro and schedule
your free HR audit make sure that you
are in compliance that you're doing all
the right things to make sure their
business is on solid footing ok so the
New York Times reports late last year a
group of first term House Democrats
anxious over the party's fractious
presidential race can mean a series of
discussions intended to spur party unity
led by representatives Colin Allred of
Texas and Hayley Stevens in Michigan
they considered issuing a collective
endorsement of one moderate candidate
the group held phone calls with Joe
Biden Amy Klobuchar NP bootie judge but
the lawmakers could not agree some were
torn between the options other others
worried about alienating voters at home
who backed other contenders like Bernie
Sanders or Elizabeth Warren a few issued
solo endorsements of Biden but the
grander plan disintegrated there wasn't
time to reach consensus over one
candidate said miss Stevens who
eventually endorsed Bloomberg that
effort was just one in a series of
abandoned or ineffective plans to rally
the moderate wing of the Democratic
Party behind a single contender but now
on the eve of Super Tuesday when
Democrats across 15 states and
territories will hand out more than a
third of the delegates required to claim
the nomination Sanders is within reach
of a clear national lead and Biden is
racing to catch up in the last few days
of moderate Democrats acting with a new
sense of urgency have begun a
large-scale effort to coalesce around
Joe Biden and this is the big story the
coalescing around Joe Biden the
consolidation around Joe Biden soapy
bootie judge who's had some fairly harsh
words for Joe Biden not as harsh as the
other candidates on the stage with
regard to Joe Biden he dropped out of
the race yesterday and then he flew to
Dallas to do a rally with Joe Biden and
Amy Klobuchar and beta O'Rourke for some
one reason and Peabody Judge basically
here's thing with Budi Judge Judy judge
was smart enough to recognize that he
has no political future in the state of
Indiana so ever after he dropped out
there were a lot of talk there's a lot
of talk well he didn't come back next
time and he can run okay first of all I
find it hilarious like to CNN was like
in 2024 he can run well first of all
thank you for admitting that Donald
Trump is gonna win in 2020 but second of
all well he'll it turns out the
politicians have moments right elizabeth
warren's moment was not 20/20 it was
2016 and people to judge had his moment
this was his moment so Pete Buddha judge
really only has two paths to a future in
politics one is a cabinet appointment he
gets appointed Secretary of
defense because of his military
background by Joe Biden or something and
the second is that people to judge ends
up carpetbagging it that he leaves the
state of Indiana and he ends up going to
the state of New York or the state of
Massachusetts he pulls a Robert Kennedy
or a Hillary Clinton and moves from a
state where he is unlikely to win to a
state where he is much more likely to
win because remember the one time he ran
statewide in Indiana he got his butt
kicked I mean just got destroyed by
Richard Murdoch of all people so he
doesn't have a future
outside of endorsing Biden he knows that
so who to judge comes out yesterday and
he endorses Biden here is mayor Pete
dropping out of the race and endorsing a
guy who until five minutes ago had not
won a single primary we made it clear
that the whole idea was about rallying
the country together to defeat Donald
Trump and to win the era for the values
that we share and that was always a goal
that was much bigger than me becoming
president and it is in the name of that
very same goal that I'm delighted to
endorse and support Joe Biden for
president we need a politics that's
about decency of politics that brings
back dignity and that is what we sought
to practice in my campaign that's what
Joe Biden has been practicing his entire
life okay so there is Budaj edge
basically bending the knee to Biden in
the hopes that Biden will give him some
sort of cabinet appointment it's
perfectly clear that that's exactly
what's going on right bootie judge is
smart enough to read the tea leaves he's
the smartest candidate in this field he
understands his future glory lies in
being some sort of cabinet level
appointee by a President Joe Biden and
so he's going to bend the knee to Joe
Biden he's not gonna get one nickel from
Bernie Sanders see here's the problem
for Sanders Sanders is so off-putting
and Sanders is so insular in the group
of people he trusts because there are a
bunch of socialists who are radicals
that he doesn't have the opportunity to
offer patronage he doesn't have the
opportunity to basically bribe these
people to to join his campaign he has
nothing to offer them like what's gonna
offer people to judge would have just
been attacking on Medicare for all right
Sanders has basically said I'm not going
to accept the endorsement of anybody who
didn't endorse Medicare for all and so
Budaj edge again the smartest candidate
in the field if not the most successful
he recognized what was going on here Joe
Biden for his part came out and embraced
Budaj edge I will say even as my Chris
Matthews impersonation dies my Joe Biden
impersonation is is be
to bloom into its full flower here here
is Joe Biden explaining that booty judge
reminds me of his son Beau who died
which has to hurt hunter right there's a
second son out there and just let just
like well yeah Pete I don't sense a lot
of people Pete is not Pete reminds me of
my son Beau and hunters out there like
snorting coke and doing hookers and and
everybody's and it's like why doesn't my
father loved me and I was like well I
have another son Hunter yeah I don't
want to talk about he's in Ukraine were
known as damn what Joe doe I don't think
I've ever done this before but he
reminds me of my son Beau and I know
much to most people but to me it's the
highest compliment I could give any
woman and again he has another son
he's never compared anyone to his son
Beau including his other son Hunter who
may cost him the presidency by the way
hunter button so there is that and then
Biden basically admits he says listen if
I win then Buddha judge gets an
administration role you know president
will get the president's response to
this which is pretty classic in one
saying here is Joe Biden being like yeah
of course if I win and then people who
judge tends to be it used to be
Secretary of Secretary of Secretary of
Indiana I don't know just something I'll
get with you on something and America
speak to people to judge a couple days
ago to encourage him to stay engage
because he has an enormous talent and I
indicated tendon if I became the nominee
I become and asked him to be part of an
administration that he being gauged in
moving things forward
it could be Secretary of Transportation
or something I don't know president
Trump's response to all of this is
pretty spot-on and pretty hilarious
Trump was like guys you know we call
that when you bribe somebody to join
your campaign you know we have a name
for that guys it's called the quid pro
quo
quid pro quo yeah
butI gates just went out and said
something and probably they'll say hey
look if I win I'll put you in the
administration that's called quid pro
quo right
quid pro quo and they probably said hey
listen if I win I'll give you an
endorsement but will you take me in the
administration now I'm sure like I'm
sure nothing like that has ever happened
right fact check true fact check true I
mean it's also true that like that's not
a deal with foreign country but in any
case in any case that isn't that is a
fact check true it turns out that that
that's exactly what happened that is
called political patronage and it wasn't
just of course people to judge yesterday
who jump behind Joe Biden it was also
Amy Klobuchar so even Klobuchar the
senator from Minnesota who again had
outperformed Joe Biden in two of the
three states that had that had taken
place before South Carolina Klobuchar
are dropped out and then she flew down
to Dallas and she endorsed Joe Biden so
this is the first time that Amy
Klobuchar and people who judge have
agreed on anything then they went in the
back room and for some reasons just
attacked Peabody judges jugular with a
comb it was very weird but here is Amy
Klobuchar explaining why she's endorsing
Joe Biden if you feel tired of the noise
in the nonsense in our politics and if
you are tired of the extremes you have a
home with me with Joe Biden it is up to
us all of us to put our country back
together to heal this country and then
to build something even greater I
believe we can do this together and that
is why today I am ending my campaign and
endorsing Joe Biden okay so these other
Democrats are smarter than the
Republicans were in 2016 because they
recognize that their pathway to glory is
getting behind somebody who is not
Bernie Sanders the entire Democratic
Party establishment is now moving
against Bernie Sanders like all of them
so you've got Harry Reid who came out
yesterday in a very non shocking move
and endorsed Joe Biden so Reid who's the
former Senate Majority and Minority
Leader he came out endorse Biden
so did former Virginia Governor Terry
McAuliffe here is Terry McAuliffe
endorsing Tobin by the way on his way to
enjoy endorse Joe Biden who's doing so
pressor yesterday apparently his
elevator got stuck like ten people in it
I cannot think of much of a worse fate
than being stuck in an elevator for two
hours with terry mcauliffe that sounds
like almost the definition of hell in
any case here is terry mcauliffe
former DNC head and former Virginia
Governor explaining why he was endorsing
Joe Biden on CNN I have a decision I
would endorse Joe Biden I'll be with him
in Norfolk tomorrow at 7 o'clock
tomorrow night he's coming up to
Virginia you know I felt long and hard
about this for me it's about beating
Donald Trump and to me it's an
electability issue who is the best shot
of beating Donald Trump you know health
care is our biggest issue that's why
Democrats win I want someone who's going
to protect Obamacare and expand
Obamacare is a Harry Reid did it as well
Harry Reid's statement was president
Donald Trump has done in speakable
damage to our country our institutions
in the rule of law Democrats need a
candidate who can assemble the largest
most diverse coalition possible to
defeat Trump and lead our country
following the trauma from presidency
that cans in it is Joe Biden so
everybody is making me pure electability
argument other endorsers in the last 48
hours
senator Tammy Duckworth of Illinois
former senators Barbara Boxer of
California
Barbara Boxer by the way the dumbest
person in the US Senate for years I mean
she held that title unchallenged for
years but she was behind Joe Biden as
well so as mark Udall of Colorado and
Blanche Lincoln of Arkansas so spate of
endorsers coming out and those weren't
the only ones Susan Rice basically Obama
called the ball his friend she said I'm
not gonna get involved but if you would
endorse stroke that'd be good
so Susan Rice an awful awful national
security advisor to Barack Obama she
came out and endorsed Joe Biden she
tweeted I'm proud to endorse Joe Biden
for president here he is comforting me
On January 4th 2017 just after my mother
passed away there is no one kinder more
empathetic and caring than Joe Biden he
will lead America with the same deep
compassion and decency okay this has
been the pitch for Biden is that Biden
is a nice guy where's Bernie he's a very
very mean guy we'll get to one more
major endorser of Joe Biden in just one
second first let's talk about replacing
employees so let's say that you have an
employee who is just the star of your
company softball team and let's say that
this will call a man call man and let's
say that this particular employee I mean
he's just a stunt on your softball team
and any take real pride in your company
softball team but in hitting a double he
just blows out his hamstrings so he
can't go to work anymore and he's just
sitting at home ice in that hammy and
thinking about how we could have won
this off
ball game last night if only if only he
had not made that wrong turn at first
base well you know at that point you
might be thinking about replacing Matt I
mean you need somebody I mean he's on
the DL you need somebody in the middle
of lineup and you need somebody who can
actually do the accounting around here
while he's healing up that hammy so why
exactly would you keep Matt around well
you check out zip recruiter that's what
you'd do you go to super occur because
zip recruiter comm daily wire allows you
to try it for free zip recruiter sends
your job to have a 100 top job sites
with their powerful matching technology
zip recruiter scans thousands of resumes
to find people with the right skills and
experience for your job and then
actively invites them to apply you can
have even add screening questions to
your job listing so you can filter
candidates and focus on the best ones
zip recruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post on zip
recruiter got a quality candidate within
the very first day here's the truth as
much as I rip on a different employee
every time we do a zipper career ad the
truth is we do take hunting extremely
seriously here at daily wire and that is
why we use zip recruiter we gotta find
candidates the best candidates in the
shortest available period of time
try zip recruiter for it yourself go to
zip recruiters comm slash daily wire
that is zip recruiter comm slash Dai ly
WI re zip recruit comm slash daily wire
keep your employees on their toes and
more importantly get some great new
employees at zip recruiters comm slash
it daily wider zip recruiter is indeed
the smartest way to hire okay so one
more big endorsement came forth for Joe
Biden yesterday and that be bed now
honestly I'm just happy I get to break
out the bait Oh impersonation like I
have all of these impersonations that
are being that are being buried in
shallow graves lately because they have
these brief flickers of light and then
their bait o is one of them he was one
of everybody everybody loved the bait Oh
impersonation well bait Oh drop out of
the race months ago and I haven't been
able to break out my bait out for a
while so bitter
endorse Biden yesterday you smoked
doobie and then just skateboard in all
cool and everything still got the same
shirt he only has one shirt and that
that shirt has gone through a beating
man from the cover of Vanity Fair it's
like being very rich in his in his
management paid for by his in-laws too
like you know being useless well he just
jet set it in in Texas and he was like
oh you know who I like I like Joe Joe
Biden's great and he's going to appoint
me Secretary of brownness Secretary of
smokin up Secretary of awesome yeah
and go go beta go tomorrow March third
2020 I will be casting my ballot for Joe
Biden we need somebody who can bring us
together and heal us we need somebody
who can reestablish the moral authority
of the United States we need somebody
who will fight for democracy here and
abroad because democracy is under attack
here and abroad we need Joe Biden and
I'll be honest with you right not only
do we need to abide and we need a
president who's not gonna ban all the
deodorant because let me tell you my pit
stains are horrendous in this particular
video brah now here's what's scary isn't
it Joe Biden did make a promise
apparently to bado as well because this
is what again no corruption no it's all
just out of principle guys so I do love
how politics works it's pretty great so
Joe Biden is like well you know I like
Pernod barrows barrows grant and his
Batum and Aurora can and he you know he
said he's gonna ban all the guns and I
don't hate guns but I'm gonna put bado
in charge of the of the guns guns are
things that fire in the air you take a
shotgun do it twice in the air that's
what I did scare off robbers I remember
one time in 1922 my house is being
robbed and I don't really remember which
house or where all I remember is Winston
Churchill was there and Nelson Mandela
too and and Beto's gonna run our guns
program I wanna make something clear I'm
gonna guarantee you this is not last
year's seat of this guy you're gonna
take care of the gun follow with me
you're gonna be the one
leads this effort you're gonna take off
was gonna camera guy in this you know it
honestly guys you know I've been
proponent for a long time of the idea
that English ought to be the national
language Joe Biden Nancy Pelosi Donald
Trump these people are proof positive
that English needs to be the national
language we must establish English as
the national language so that everybody
is mandated to speak the language we all
understand Joe Biden has it's basically
one wrong word now his entire campaign
has devolved into one long word and I
mean it's not just him saying it to to
bethe O'Rourke and he I'm putting in
charge of gonna put a mother's gun
George where I get him also would you
like to hear Joe Biden recite the
Declaration of Independence would you
would you like to hear it because it's
spectacular and it's real and it's great
so here is Joe Biden
explaining what the Declaration of
Independence says this is the guy they
chose you had a million candidates and
the one you chose is this one
of all the humans on the earth this
human with the head in which the hair
plugs have grown deeply into the
synapses into the neural firing
mechanisms here is Joe Biden trying to
recite the Pledge of Independence and
Thomas Jefferson just spun so hard in
his grave he dug a hole directly to
China and acquired a coronavirus here is
here is Joe by oh go you know this you
know the thing oh but so you know this
you know the thing resolve everything
no minimum Avenue name is everywhere
created members Union all better when we
created a minimum goal you know this you
know the thing but anybody you know
my crew did you know by the minimum an
intimate by you know the thing Jeff
Goldblum the thing you know the movie
that's the fly I remember one time I saw
a thing it was it was from Fantastic
Four it looked like a brick there's a
minimum diminutive damage of the creek
well done everyone
well done by the way were you aware so I
made fun of a toe I'm gonna go because
band over rock started his little
endorsement of Joe Biden by explaining
that today you just said tomorrow cuz
yesterday he said today his Tuesday yes
tomorrow is Tuesday Super Tuesday March
3rd well I mean I made fun of him for
saying that but maybe he was just trying
to tell Joe Biden because Joe Biden
actually said yesterday that tomorrow is
super Thursday which doesn't exist and I
know it's super Thursday is where he's
getting this but um here's Joe Biden's
job isn't in a super into them Wednesday
maneuvers at home look tomorrow
superstar Susie and I want to thank you
all even everything got a Russian head
on his knee and Thursday magenta okay
guys I mean I I hope all the candidates
should live long and be well all I'm
gonna say is that I feel like the
country is in severe danger because
coronavirus is only killing people above
65 and we only nominate people above 65
so that's all I'm gonna say about that
hey meanwhile meanwhile Bernie is
feeling a little bit left out in the
cold
man this is getting to be fun Bernie's
feeling a little bit upset we're gonna
get to that in just one second first
have you ever been in that weird
situation where partner your car breaks
down and I got to take an uber over to
the auto parts store you go there they
don't have the part or you go there they
have a generic part of cost too much
money why are you not using the
interwebs are you not aware it is 2020
and we have a thing called the interwebs
are you Joe Biden you believe that it's
1916 and you're just trying to avoid the
Spanish flu well instead you should be
using the Internet Rock Auto calm
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like airlines do well I spend up to
twice as much for the same parts the
rockauto.com catalog is unique
remarkably easy to navigate rockauto.com
has everything from engine control
modules and brake parts to tail lamps
motor oil even new carpet whether it's
for classic or daily driver get
everything you need in a few easy clicks
delivered directly to your door Rocco
it's a family business serving Auto
Parts customers online for 20 years head
on over in rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your car or
truck right shapiro in there how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you head on over to Rock Auto calm
right now make sure that you're getting
any proper part for your car or truck
and that you're not getting job by
companies that are going to charge you a
different price whether you're an
experts or whether you are a novice
instead go check out rockauto.com get
the best parts available and right
Shapiro's in their hair did you hear
about us box so they know that we saying
okay meanwhile Bernie brightly is
looking at this and going the Democratic
Party it's time to stop by what they
doing I couldn't believe it that stabbed
me in the back it's just like 2016 and
or like when Stalin push blendin down
the down the stairs and killed him I
mean that was good and we got Stalinism
it's exactly the same so Bernie's very
mad about this he says it's not a
surprise to me that are coming customi
of course they're coming after me this
is what the kulaks always do the
culottes are always coming after me
Bernie Sanders Leninist is no secret the
Washington Post has 16 articles today on
this then there is a massive effort
trying to stop Perdue sense that's not a
secret to anybody in this room are the
corporate establishment is coming
together the political establishment is
coming together and they will do
everything really well mostly they're
nervous that you're an old loon bag
commie
and they're afraid you're gonna lose her
Trump but he was correct he's correct
obviously the party is mobilized all the
heads of the party do not wanna see
Bernie as the nominee and again I think
it shows a impressive discipline to be
honest with you it is a discipline party
it's one of the reasons why the
Democratic Party typically has been more
popular with its own constituents than
the Republican Party the party apparatus
among Democrats is still very much
operational it's completely
dysfunctional with Republicans the
Republican party apparatus does not
exist which is why Trump was able to run
in and just take over the entire party
well Bernie tried it and now the
establishment is kicking back and they
are saying no Sanders was asked directly
by Anderson Cooper last night on CNN if
the Democrats are stealing the
nomination from him again and Bernie's
like I'm not gonna answer that question
I mean maybe they are maybe that's
stealing did not normally I'm the only
one who steals from people I just come
and take that money but now the
Democrats keep trying to steal the
nomination from me did they be stopped
it
but here's Bernie getting mad again
they're here we'll get to the
implications of the burning versus Biden
showdown and the fact that no one's
gonna have a majority of Delegates going
in in just one second but here is Bernie
refusing to answer if the Democrats are
stealing the nomination from him Trump a
question last night the timing of Buda
Tricia's withdrawal tweeting in part
this is the real beginning of the Dems
taking Bernie out of play no nomination
again he also tweeted this afternoon
quote they are staging a coup against
you is he right
you know what I really wish that the
President of the United States might
kind of spend his time doing his job
maybe just maybe he might want to worry
about the corona virus
hit the corona virus a virus that is
made from beer I don't like beer I like
I like vodka like my Russian compatriots
and any case he won't answer it right he
he rips on from because that's always
the convenient out but he's not saying
and the answer is that the Bernie bros
feel like this is being stolen and if
you watch the Bernie bros online they
are making this very clear Trump of
course is stoking those flames right
Trump is just like go for it Trump
tweets out they are staging a coup
against Bernie now of course they're not
staging a coup against Bernie it's
called a normal election process but
that's not Trump is doing that all right
Trump doesn't actually think that
they're staging a coup again maybe it
does but who cares what he's actually
doing there is trying to stoke the
flames of division inside the Democratic
Party Sanders yesterday he's getting
more and more ticked off as he is the
front-runner he has never felt actual
scrutiny Bernie
when he gets when you're the outsider
and you got to aim fire at everybody
else you're not the one who faces the
scrutiny and so Bernie went through an
entire election cycle where he was the
outsider and Hillary was the insider and
up until this point he was able to play
that card because Biden was the guy who
was gonna win the nomination and Bernie
was just gonna be outside sniping at him
then
Bernie became the front-runner all that
all the spotlights swiveled and hit him
like the end of Stalag 17 all the
spotlights in the place went and just
hit him and all of a sudden the machine
guns are aimed at him and Bernie starts
to lose it so Bernie is getting more and
more angry on the campaign trail which
is not his best look honestly sort of a
funky allure honest guy was always his
best look but angry communists it turns
out not supremely popular so you asked
yesterday whether he was you know why he
keeps campaigning as a socialist why
people keep calling him a socialist and
Bernie Sanders answered
the Popeye answer I am what I am and
that's all that I am and then he downed
a can of spinach was real weird here's
Bernie explaining chair a congressman
wrote kana I told the Wall Street
Journal and he's been trying to convince
you to portray yourself differently as a
successor of Franklin Roosevelt and as a
new dealer do you ever regret labeling
yourself a Democratic Socialist no I am
what I am I am what I am that's all that
I am I'm sprung to the finish when I eat
my spinach
he's Popeye the Sailor communist Michael
Moore then came out and he says it's
really sad that people are thinking of
how to stop Bernie instead of stopping
from you can see they're already in
there already in mourning right the
Democrats on the Bernie side they're
already in mourning they think it's
being stolen and they are pissed
they are super pissed so I'm gonna give
you the coming up in just a moment I'm
gonna give you the sort of breakdown of
the possible options that happen after
Bernie after Super Tuesday well we'll
give you the delegate breakdowns one of
the possibilities here moving forward
none of them are good for Democrats this
is all a disaster for Democrats but
Michael Moore you know obviously already
in pre-emptive mourning for Bernie
Sanders's campaign here he is explaining
that people should stop thinking about
Bernie and said they should think about
Trump but of course neglecting the fact
the reason that people don't want Bernie
to be the nominee is specifically
because they think that Bernie can't be
Trump that's the whole point I think
they're falling in line third I think
you tonight about who can stop Donald
Trump they're thinking about who could
stop Bernie Sanders and it's sad to see
that and it's sad for anybody that would
be thinking about voting for Biden
because they're afraid they're voting
out of fear if you're afraid of Trump
now that's what we're really is behind
this that if you go if you vote for a
candidate that we take fear into the
general election running on fear we will
lose to trump if we will vote on fear um
well you might lose to trump if you try
to elect a communist I mean though
that's that's what most of the Democrats
are thinking just a second I'm gonna
give you the breakdown of what could
happen going forward and none of these
scenarios are good for the Democrats
they're all a real problem for Democrats
against that in a second first Super
Tuesday is upon us an octogenarian
communist is in the lead to face off
against President Trump but Joe Biden an
actual dead person is now gaining on him
quickly now Bernie Sanders were to run
this company
everything here would be free free
memberships free advertising free
pudding cups and
killed the kulaks to pay for it but in
reality that would make us go bankrupt
very quickly unless we killed the kulaks
to pay for it nevertheless we still have
some great savings in store for you
right now you can become a daily wire
member for 25% off on any plan using
coupon code never socialist I don't know
about you guys but savings like these
always make my tumblr overflow with
leftist years daily wire members get an
ad-free website experience access to all
of our live broadcasts and show library
the full 3 hours of the bishop arrow
show access to the mailbag and now
exclusive election insight op-eds from
yours truly join us for special events
like Super Tuesday episode of daily wire
backstage or we'll be breaking down and
covering all of the Super Tuesday
election updates in real time that is
correct we'll be here unless my wife is
in labor in which case I'll still try to
beat her for part of the time but my
wife will murder me if she's actually in
labor now in any case we will hope and
pray that she holds off I also want to
announce that Sunday's special is back
they kicked off the first episode of the
season yesterday with controversial
guest charlie Kirk from Turning Point
USA watched I asked him some tough
questions about Trump and he answers why
he believes that the magg of you is the
only view worth worth noting daily where
members get to watch special bonus
content available only at daily wire.com
along with all of us of course you get
the magnificent irreplaceable singular
leftist here's tumblr if you haven't
already download the daily wire app so
you get all of our great content on the
go again that is 20% 25% off on daily
wire memberships for all plans using
coupon code never socialist Super
Tuesday calls for super savings so head
on over to daily wire.com slash
subscribe
act now before it's too late that is
Daily wire.com slash subscribe also we
want to hear from you tell us who you
think will win the Democratic nomination
by texting either Biden Bernie Bloomberg
or Warren 283 400 if you text Warren we
know you're not serious and on Tuesday
night during our daily wire backstage
we'll analyze the results live in fact
there will be only one text for
Elizabeth Warren it will be from
Elizabeth Warren again text either Biden
blue Bernie Bloomberg or Warren 283 400
will analyze the results on daily wire
backstage tonight tonight Super Tuesday
you're listening to the fast largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so here are the scenarios
here are the scenarios the 538 is now
pegging it that Joe Biden will be the
leader in terms of delegates going into
the convention he will not have a
majority Bernie Sanders will follow him
closely also not with a majority
obviously he'll have a not even
plurality and then they're there they're
thinking that Bloomberg wins something
like 500 delegates I think that is wild
overestimate for blue wild over estimate
for Bloomberg I think Bloomberg
significantly under performs tonight I
that I may be wrong I think I will be
surprised if Bloomberg wins more than
about 40 delegates tonight seriously I
think the Bloomberg is not gonna cross
15 percent nearly any state I think he's
going to completely collapse once the
voters have a chance to actually vote
for Biden or Bloomberg I think people
gonna vote for Biden okay so I think the
Biden significantly over performs I
think Bernie performs exactly in line
with expectations and I think
Bloomberg's votes I'll go to Biden
basically also Klobuchar and Budaj
endorsed by didn't so I would assume
that most of those voters not all of
them but most of them ends up moving
over to Joe Biden as well this least the
possibility of three scenarios the
worst-case scenario is the scenario in
which Sanders cleans up tonight but
Biden gains and by the time of the
convention
Sanders ends up with slightly more
delegates than Biden and Bloomberg ends
up with like 500-600 elegance right that
is the worst case scenario let's say
that Biden ends up with 1,500 delegates
and Bloomberg ends up the 600 elegance
and Bernie ends up with 17 hundred
delegates Bernie's not gonna get the
nomination in that case because the
rules state you have to win a majority
of the delegates but Bernie's gonna
claim that having won plurality of the
delegates he should be hands in the
nomination as the leader in the
clubhouse he should be allowed to have
the nomination and anything else is
stealing the nomination from him Biden
is gonna claim hey guys like if
Bloomberg weren't in the race I
obviously win this thing Bloomberg
throws his delegates over to Biden they
have a combined Biden Bloomberg ticket
or something or he makes Bloomberg the
head of one of his department's one of
his agencies and then they take the
nomination Bernie feels like he has jobs
or alternatively the party has to give
it to Sanders and the entire moderate
wing just checks out and not only do
they check out all the money checks out
which is really the big issue right the
entire money my like everyone who has
any cash and the Democratic Party is not
on board when they full-on socialist
that is worst case scenario for the
Democrats so honestly I'm kind of
rooting for it right Bernie ends up with
the most elegance but not a majority
Biden finishes a close second right that
is that is full chaos at the convention
that is
worst-case scenario then there's the
best-case scenario best-case scenario
his Biden's comeback is complete he wins
a plurality of the delegates Bloomberg
pulls out but keeps spending on anti
Bernie ads crushing Bernie Bernie ends
up in second place and doesn't have a
real case for the nomination and then he
just claims victory for his movement now
that's still not great for the Democrats
in the sense that Bernie's people are
grievance mongers this is their entire
political campaign their entire
political campaign is that the system is
rigged the system is corrupt and so
they're gonna say listen Bernie was in
the lead until the entire Democratic
Party infrastructure mobilized behind
Joe Biden and so really Bernie got
jobbed again
now they claimed this in 2016 because
Hillary did win the majority of the
delegates right she she had the majority
of the delegates she won more votes than
Bernie Sanders but people were still
claiming that Bernie got screwed out of
it because the DNC was interfering he
can make the same case right now given
the fact that there is this obvious
mobilization on behalf of Biden this
obvious consolidation of the field on
behalf of Biden so even if Biden were to
walk into the convention with a
plurality of Delegates bernie is still
going to claim that he got screwed out
of it and so are his people and that's a
real problem for the Democrats even if
Bernie gives us sort of lackluster
half-hearted endorsement of Joe Biden
that's gonna have exactly the same
impact as as Bernie doing that in 2016
with Hillary Clinton namely a bunch of
Bernie supporters and be like I don't
care about this I'm not in I'm not in
here is the big problem for the Democrat
and then finally there's the the
anything-goes scenario dead-heat know
one situation Democrats try to go off
the board for somebody like Michelle
Obama unlikely very very unlikely the
most unlikely okay so here's the problem
for the Democrats there were two there
were there were three things that the
Democratic Party did wrong I mean really
like three serious things one they
rejiggered the primary process to help
popular but non majoritarian candidates
like Bernie at Bernie's behest so Bernie
claimed last time around who's screwed
so the Democratic Party responded by
releasing raw vote totals in places like
Iowa they responded by getting rid of
the impact of super-delegates making it
appear that Bernie had more of a shot at
bucking the party infrastructure that
was big mistake number one big mistake
number two letting Bernie run as a
Democrat without actually being a
Democrat and then hijacking his platform
right everybody decided to hijack
Bernie's platform and decided to be mini
Bernie's and at that point
Bernie became the most honest guy in the
field and there was a sort of
consolidation that happened behind
Bernie right so letting Bernie
into the game in the first place and
then rigging the game to try and help
Bernie to horrible decisions and finally
the decision by Biden to run a horrible
lackluster campaign so even if Biden
pulls out the nomination Biden will have
done severe damage to them on credit
card he been running such a crap
campaign why because he opened the door
wide to Sanders which ends up allowing
the Sanders supporters to feel jobs by
Biden winning the nomination imagine if
Biden had not run a crappy campaign
imagine if Biden raised money and spent
in Iowa and spent in New Hampshire and
he'd won the first couple of contests
there wouldn't been a split in the party
but now that Bernie actually was for a
short time the delegate leader and may
still be the delegate leader after Super
Tuesday give him California now no
matter what happens because Biden ran
the world's crappiest campaign it ends
up that have a major split inside the
party so this is almost best-case
scenario for President Trump Trump is
just overjoyed about all this and he
should be now meanwhile Bernie is sort
of praying that Michael Bloomberg does
better than expected in these various in
these various Super Tuesday states
there's only one problem which is that
Bloomberg is awful at this yesterday
Bloomberg did another one of these CNN
Town Hall's and he was confronted on gun
control it did not go well for him
actually on Fox News rather it did not
go well for him justify pushing for more
gun control when you have an armed
security detail that is likely equipped
with the same firearms and magazines
that you seek to ban the common citizen
from owning does your life matter more
than mine or my families or these
people's I probably get 40 or 50 threats
every week okay and some of them are
real that just happens when you have a
mayor in New York City or you're very
wealthy and if you're campaigning for
president United States you get lots of
threats okay that is that is the worst
dancer ever basically I deserve it
because I can afford it and also I get
lots of threats so I should be able to
pursue myself but you should not be able
to protect yourself horrible answer by
Bloomberg again I think Bloomberg falls
flat on his face today I think Bloomberg
has an awful awful evening and I think
that benefits mainly Joe Biden okay
meanwhile the other big story of
yesterday it's a loss to may slice to
America it's nice to everybody Chris
Matthews just left he show hardball I
would say safe come on in here coming at
the show a run book and say things just
show metaphors similes alliteration
just lots of things coming here just say
things last night Cruz Matthews got
so after 23 years doing hardball a lot
of hardball right there
lots and lots of it get I said you know
what I've had it I'm mad as how I'm not
gonna take it anymore I'm leaving and
you guys tell stick it now he makes an
excuse he says the reason I'm doing is
the time to pass me by at times pass me
by because we've moved into a more woke
era he gives a quasi apology his
quizmaster give me a quasi apology and
saying you know what I'm out
Matthew's out mic drop Chris Matthews go
no I mean like actually go like leave
but go go Chris Matthews go let me start
with my headline tonight I'm retiring
this is the last hardball at MSNBC and
obviously this isn't for lack of
interest in politics as you can tell
I've loved every minute of my 20 years
as host of hardball the younger
generations out there are ready to take
the reins we see them in politics in the
media and fighting for their causes they
are proving the workplace we're talking
here about better standards than we grew
up with fair standards a lot of it has
to do with how we talk to each other
compliments on a woman's appearance that
some men including me might have once
incorrectly thought were okay we're
never okay not then is certainly not
today and for making such comments in
the past I'm sorry okay and then he'll a
said he says you know what I'm out I'm
done
catch you later and and this was
somewhat hilarious because Steve
Kornacki was obviously taken by surprise
but Steve Karnak is just on the set
doing Elections analysis and he's like
um and they're like guess who's the new
host of hardball who drew the short
straw
Steve Kornacki congratulations you're
the hockey on air last night was like um
hi everyone I'm your new host Steve
Kornacki zesty cocky and MSNBC trying to
soldier through this they mean credit to
Steve Kornacki honestly that was a lot
to take in just now I'm sure and I'm
sure you're still absorbing that and and
I am too Chris Matthews is a giant he's
a legend it's been an honor for me to
work with him to sit in here on occasion
and I know how much you meant to him and
I know how much he meant to you
and I think you're gonna miss him and I
know I'm going to
not having bells or whistles here we do
have to fill the rest this hour we're
taking a quick break and come back with
news hey I don't have a teleprompter and
I don't know what to do and you know
what good for Chris Matthews honestly
like seriously good for him because
Chris Matthews was like I'm getting
dropped out of here
right that's what okay so what really
happened here is that Chris Matthews
does Chris Matthews for 23 years and he
was wildly entertaining okay Chris
Matthews the reason I imitate him is
because yes he says silly things a lot
but also dude is entertaining okay Chris
Matthews was fun he was fun to watch
okay and Chris man he was great I loved
it every moment every moment she said a
little tingle up my leg spikes of joy
like Marie Kondo on TV unbelievable and
the reason he was ousted is because the
woke bros decided to get him there were
two there were two basic incidents that
happened over the last month she was
fine neither of them was a big deal one
of them was where he suggested that the
Democratic Party was waking up like the
like the Allies in 1940 and realizing
that the Germans had taken over the
beaches basically he was not comparing
Bernie Sanders to a Nazi and you have to
be a to believe that he was doing
that didn't matter the burning rose
don't like Chris Matthews because Chris
Matthews happens to be an anti-communist
right happens not to like socialism
happens not to like communism Chris
Matthews is moderate enough to
understand the nationalization of
industry it's a stupid idea so the
burning bros got very mad and then they
played this idiotic game where they
suggested that chris matthews was
anti-semitic meanwhile their candidate
is out campaigning with actual people
who want to wipe the state of israel off
the map I mean it was really cynical and
really gross and I mentioned it at the
time right in the last month I become a
Chris Matthews defender not just cuz I
like my impression but also because the
attacks on him were really unfair then
there's this interview he did with
Elizabeth Warren where Elizabeth Warren
was cynically going after Michael
Bloomberg and suggesting that Michael
Bloomberg hat was lying about his his
confrontations with the series of women
in his office and Bloomberg had said I'm
not lying about that you know we there
are NBA's in place but I'm not lying
about that and obviously people have a
rather large incentive to say I say
things that I didn't say because I'm
extremely wealthy I run a huge company
so Chris Matthews is questioning
Elizabeth Warren about this and this of
course is a big no-no sierra's chris
matthews being a vicious sexist by
asking a basic question everybody
deserves incredible response when they
make
charge like that my question about him
you believe he's lying I believe the
woman you believe he's not telling the
truth
and why would he live because just to
protect himself Jail and why would she
lie but that's the question Chris why do
you try keep that got to make sure
you're clear about this you're confident
of your accusation look all I know is
what she said and what he said okay that
is not sexist nothing and he says
they're a sexist and by the way believe
all woman is a bunch of crap everybody
knows it's a bunch of crap there's a
reason why the Democrats don't believe
all women and it kind of depending on
the woman okay so the fact is that he
didn't say anything there that is
supremely off-limits didn't matter
people went nuts whose sexist who said
how could he ask Elizabeth Warren if a
woman lied about Bloomberg well she's
accusing a man of lying so like why
would you believe the woman as opposed
to believing the man in this particular
scenario as far as why would she lie the
answer is she was filing a lawsuit
against Bloomberg against the time who
happens to be extremely wealthy so yeah
that might be a good reason I mean that
doesn't mean that she's not telling
maybe she's telling I don't know you
don't know I mean Chris Matthews is
saying Elizabeth Warren you don't know
either so like what's her evidence okay
he got ripped up and down for this
Tianna low over the Washington Examiner
has a good piece on this she says the
hosts departure which she said resulted
after a conversation with MSNBC hardly
came out of the blue for months
Matthew's another host challenging 2020
frontrunner Bernie Sanders have faced
the ire of the socialist senators fans
as well as those of Elizabeth Warren and
only now to the network apparently care
that for years rumors of inappropriate
behavior of swirls around Matthews this
is right so people are saying okay well
it's just because of all these stuff
that he said back in 2002 women okay
well you know what your it is 20/20 you
know that stuff has been around for
quite a while right at the onset of the
me2 movement in late 2017 The Daily
Caller uncovered a settlement paid out
by NBC to a swage a former employee of
Mathews who alleged sexual harassment
shortly thereafter multiple sources
alleged that Matthews created an abusive
work environment other reporters
corroborated the payout and additional
details but despite other serial sexual
harassers facing punishment Matthews
continued on as usual until he got under
the skin of Warren fans and Bernie bros
just days after he likens Sanders his
victory in Nevada to the fall of France
to the Nazis
he pressed Warren on an on her invoking
the allegation that Bloomberg told the
female employee to have an abortion and
bring Sanders and Warren fans is a good
way to alienate a substantial portion of
the MSNBC audience Warren defender Laura
Bassett compared it as his aggressive
questioning of the Massachusetts senator
so the objectifying comments she faced
from Matthews three years ago that MSNBC
decided to take action against a
credible accusation isn't the problem
that they waited this long is and that
of course is exactly right okay that is
exactly right okay so the bottom line is
that they were fine with whatever Chris
Matthews did before it is only now that
it's a problem and the reason that it's
a problem is because Chris Matthews is
cutting against the grain at MSNBC by
pissing off all of the Warren and
Sanders supporters that's all that
really happened here so maybe he
deserved to get the axe back in 2017
based on what he was saying to women I
don't know maybe sure why not
but they didn't do anything about it
they settled it and now they're coming
after Bert and now they're coming after
Matthews for that reason know that that
is that is cynical manipulation so we
bid a fond farewell Chris Matthews
honestly I'm I'm more sad that the
impressions can go away what opportunity
am I gonna have them let me take Chris
Matthews I don't know hopefully in the
future Chris Matthews will come back in
some iteration so we can use it
otherwise gonna have to mothball this
thing so Godspeed my impression Godspeed
and may you see happier days in the
heaven of impersonations all right time
for a thing I like and then a thing I
hate
so things that I like today so somehow
Bibi Netanyahu is some sort of political
magician so according to The Jerusalem
Post Benjamin Netanyahu has now defeated
Bennigan's he is still short of majority
the exit polls in Israel are a little
bit ahead of the actual voting results
so late yesterday it appeared that that
Netanyahu on the right-wing block had an
actual outright majority instead the
exit polls now suggest that Netanyahu is
on tracks when 59 seats for his bloc of
right wing and religious parties in
Monday's election down by one from the
60 predicted by initial exit polls that
prediction leads into seats short of
majority in the Knesset the first polls
indicated that Netanyahu's Likud won 36
to 37 seats its allies in Shas utj and
yummy no.19 7 to 8 and 67 the polls
showed that blue and white only won 33
seats that Labour which is the left-wing
party in Israel with won 6 to 7 the
joint list which is the Arab parties who
by the way overtly call for the
abolition of the State of Israel sit at
14 to 15 and you stir all betánia which
is sort of the swing voting bloc six to
eight seats the numbers are expected to
continue to change the votes of soldiers
have not yet been counted the joint list
tends to lose a seat when the soldiers
votes are added if the right doesn't
obtain in 60 first steep it could end up
because the far-right Oats may hoody
party refused in its in Yahoo's repeated
requests to quit the race so now the
only question is whether they can peel
off one or two votes whether the blue
and white constituency which is
basically just an anti denied in Yahoo
Party weather a few of them say listen
we're done with this we've done three
elections in a year we this has to end
and they join it to Yahoo's coalition
bottom line is that Netanyahu was
basically given up for dead after the
last election the conventional wisdom
suggested that with the indictment
coming down for corruption against
Netanyahu that people are going to
abandon Likud in droves this was what
people in blue and white were saying I
said that was not going to happen I
suggested that you were gonna end up
with a new election in all likelihood
Bibi actually surpassed those
expectations people are angry they're
angry the blue and white continues to
hold this thing up and by the way the
longer the Bibi continues as Prime
Minister of Israel the better for Bibi
because the big issue in Israel is
whether Bibi Netanyahu was going to be
tried for corruption in Tel Aviv or in
Jerusalem and this would be the
equivalent of his president Trump gonna
be tried for corruption in Austin Texas
or is gonna be tried for corruption in
Lubbock Texas right the venue makes an
awful lot of difference right if he's
tried in Lubbock he's fine if he's tried
in Austin he's going to jail for life
the same thing is true of Bibi Netanyahu
if he were not Prime Minister she would
be tried in Tel Aviv which is a city
that hates Benjamin Netanyahu if he was
tried in Jerusalem he probably gets a
slap on the wrist wrist which is
basically a more appropriate response to
all of us and then continues as a prime
minister all this is over in blue and
white liquidates blue and white made a
serious strategic error okay they made a
serious strategic error I've been saying
this for months
back in October when the last election
took place they obviously should have
formed a unity government with Netanyahu
they should have had a rotating prime
ministership that would've been their
best move instead they decided to sit
outside and snipe at Netanyahu and the
Israeli voters got tired of it and they
decided they were not gonna reward blue
and white for all of this they were
simply not going to continue giving blue
and white their votes in the same
numbers they had been before simply cuz
they don't like Netanyahu so another
stunning political victor proponents now
who at the very least he remains in
power for the foreseeable future even
without even if there's another election
that means that that election is not
gonna happen til summer the trial starts
March 17th that means it happens in
Jerusalem which means the Bibi is
probably going to be slapped on the
wrists are acquitted within a couple of
months and that means by the time the
next election comes around that's a big
win for Netanyahu if he's acquitted or
if he gets a slap on the wrist this
thing is over next election Likud wins a
broad majority one of the great wise
they're going to see in the Western
is that this is all about Bibi it is not
all about baby is clearly not all about
baby the fact is the Israeli public is
overwhelmingly conservative on foreign
policy issues at this point they are not
making a deal with terrorists it doesn't
matter how much the Democrats pressure
them they've made deals with terrorists
for 30 years and all they got were
thousands of dead israelis I'm not gonna
do it again the fact is the blue and
white party is not significant they
embrace the Trump peace plan the blue
and white party so the blue and white
party is not significantly different on
foreign policy than liquid party that
means that there are in total something
like ninety five seats in Knesset out of
120 that are center to center right in
Israel Israel has learned it's lesson
they're not making peace deals with
terrorists anymore despite the wishes of
the Democratic Party nor should they
because the fact is that you know who
else doesn't care about making
concessions to terrorists any more any
of the surrounding Arab nations Saudi
doesn't care Jordan doesn't care UAE
doesn't care Egypt doesn't care none of
them care none of them care Morocco
doesn't care like none of them care so
that means that regard like Bibi is
almost secondary to all of us bottom
line is that Israel has moved right
Israel is staying right it is not going
to stop being right so long as they're
faced with the prospect of a terrorist
group in charge of the people right next
door and an Iranian regime that is
threatening them from abroad so that is
the that is the thing that I like today
again Bibi is great at what he does he's
a great campaigner he is he's he's like
Trump in the sense that he drives
enormous loyalty he also is unlike Trump
in that he is strategically very clever
he is much more focused in his sort of
attack than Trump it's one of the
relevance I have back Trump is it from
put a little bit more strategically
focused you'd be a 55% and all of the
polls going into 2020 okay time for a
quick thing that I hate so the United
States is desperately attempting to get
out of Afghanistan the Trump
administration wants out they don't want
any of our military members there and
this has been pushed by the right there
are a lot of folks on the right who are
saying the war in Afghanistan is over
we lost okay we did not lose the war in
Afghanistan it's just that there is no
victory that is attainable in the sense
of establishing a stable democracy in
Afghanistan any time soon the question
is whether to keep what is effectively a
skeleton force in Afghanistan or whether
to pull out precipitously in handy handy
the keys to the car back to the Taliban
which is of course a terrorist group
so Taliban supposedly had pledged that
they weren't going to attack Afghan
targets there
going to attack the Americans they had
pledged they weren't gonna work with
al-qaeda
they are Islamic fundamentalist radicals
who engage in terrorism the Trump
administration had been engaged in
exactly the same sort of wish casting
that the Obama administration was that
maybe a deal would be able to be cut
with the Taliban it turns out that that
has fallen apart almost immediately so
the Trump administration it sends out
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo to make
the rounds suggesting that the Taliban
had committed to not working with al
Qaeda there's nothing in the deal about
that that they had committed to ending
terrorism there was no deal about that
within a day within a day they ended
their partial truth truce and started
attacking American and and Afghanistan
Afghan targets again by the way the
Afghanistan government was not on board
with any of this so it was very weird
the United States was negotiating with
the Taliban without the direct
involvement of the duly elected
government of Afghanistan that is in
place that's a very weird thing and not
only that the United States was pledging
to released 5,000 Taliban prisoners were
not being held by the Americans they're
being held by the Afghan government says
strengthening the opposition to the
Afghan government in pulling out
according to the AFP the Taliban called
an abrupt end to a partial truce on
Monday just two days after signing a
deal with the United States those meant
to bring peace at last to Afghanistan in
the southern province of Kandahar
considered the Taliban Heartland
fighting broke out in at least two
districts they started attacking five of
our post in panwa he and Maiwand
local police chief Sultan Muhammad Hakim
Ian told AFP fighting is ongoing the
Taliban ordered its fighters to
recommence attacks against Afghan army
and police forces
apparently ending an official reduction
in violence that had seen a dramatic
drop in bloodshed and given Afghans who
welcomed taste of relative calm the
partial truce between the u.s. the
insurgents and Afghan forces lasted for
a week running up to the signing of the
u.s. Taliban accord in Doha on Saturday
and was extended over the weekend the
Taliban spokesman Sabah Houla Mujahid
told AFP
the reduction in violence has ended now
and our operations will continue as
normal so they bought basically like a
week of a week of reduction in violence
well done everybody as per the u.s.
Taliban agreements our Mujahideen will
not attack foreign forces but our
operations will continue against the
Kabul administration forces in other
words there's no actual truce here
basically they're just saying if the
Americans leave we won't attack more
Americans well ok if the Americans leave
there won't be any more Americans for
you to attack so what exactly is the
peace deal what exactly is achieved
what's the negotiation the answer is
there is no negotiation when one side is
with draw and the other decided to
determine not to one will draw the other
will not and things will go back to the
way that they were and again the
question here is not endless war nobody
wants tens of thousands of troops in
Afghanistan
no one wants endless wars the question
is whether to keep a skeleton force in
Afghanistan to tamp down the Taliban's
ability to take over the government
again and then immediately provide a
recruiting station for terrorism cuz
that's what the Taliban did last time
and I'm old enough to remember 9/11 I
know that a lot of people are not it's
amazing how fast time move in almost 20
years since 9/11 but I'm old enough to
remember 9/11 a 9/11 was not something
that I would like to see repeated
because we withdraw precipitously from
an area where al-qaeda is still active
the United States caution and immediate
halt violence had not been expected
general mark Milley chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff said the Taliban
is not a monolithic group there's
multiple terrorist organizations
operating to think that violence is
going to go to zero immediately that's
probably not going to be the case so now
this is the problem with signing peace
deals with terrorist groups you end up
becoming PR spokespeople for the
terrorist groups you saw this from the
Obama administration to the Obama
administration kept saying things like
well you know if you look at Iran Iran
is not actually pursuing terrorism they
became a PR spokesperson because they
were signing a deal with the Iranians
they became a PR spokes agency for the
Iranian government now you have the
United States downplaying Taliban
violence against the legitimate
government of Afghanistan in order to
make an excuse for why we should
withdraw now again you want to enthrall
withdraw but understand their costs
understand their costs too withdrawing
and the cost withdrawing do include the
prospect of future violence down the
road the easy position and form Powell's
have discussed this at length the easy
position in foreign policy is always
bring the troops home
why because immediate benefits long-term
downsides okay but the immediate
benefits are immediately and the
long-term downsides accrue long term
okay let's say that you pull out now
let's say ten years from now there's a
terrorist attack in New York City by
Taliban associates by al Qaeda
well we'll look back and we'll say well
that was a mistake wasn't it to minimize
America's foreign military presence but
at the time it looked good you know how
we know that this would be exactly what
would happen because for 10 years in the
aftermath of the Cold War the Clinton
administration cut America's military
presence to the bone cut it down in town
in town and Ann Arbor was like okay with
this okay we're redeploying all of our
capital to the american side this is
good we're cutting military spending or
balancing the budget and then 9/11
happens like oh that was what we were
all that was mistake wasn't it
maybe we should been a little more
aggressive and then maybe some more
Americans would be alive again when you
think short term and not long term with
regard to foreign policy you make a
mistake and again Afghan violence is not
at the levels against American troops
that it was even five seven years ago
the Taliban has been gathering on Monday
to celebrate what they called their
defeat of the u.s. they also vowed to
continue operations against the Afghan
government until an Islamic system of
government is restored so why we are
signing some sort of peace deal and then
playing defense for the Taliban is
beyond me
it's it's an enormous enormous mistake
it's it and the fact that will you know
that we're down to short-term benefit
again I'm old enough to remember when
Republicans criticized Barack Obama for
precipitously withdrawing American
troops from Iraq resulting in the rise
of Isis it would not be long before the
same thing happened in Afghanistan and
by the way I mean what I mean not long I
mean like within 48 hours of signing a
deal so let's let's not play defense on
behalf of the Taliban guys if you're
gonna both draw withdraw but don't be
dishonest about why we're drawing and
suggest that a peaceful future is in the
offing for the Taliban and the Afghan
government already we'll be back here
later today with much more Super Tuesday
content as we approach the big day will
Joe Biden pull it out will Bernie
Sanders lengthen his lead who knows well
I mean I have some speculation but we'll
get to that a little bit later on in the
day otherwise stop by daily wire comm we
have a Super Tuesday broadcast for you
tonight we'll be covering the results
alive and in color so go check that out
tonight baby coming on subscribe you can
ask us questions we have a cavalcade of
comedy stars so check that out tonight
over at daily wire calm otherwise we'll
see you here tomorrow for the recap of
all the big news I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the bettin Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas
directed by Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling assistant director pavel white
house key technical producer austin
stevens playback and media operated by
nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets audio is
mixed by Mike foramina hair and makeup
is by Anika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 20 20 a me Klobuchar drops
out of the race chris matthews drops out
of MSNBC and joe biden has a super
monday we will examine how the Dems are
pulling out all the stops to stop Bernie
before Super Tuesday MSNBC pushes chris
matthews out after 20 years we'll take a
look at the bogus me to reasoning and
then go deeper to what's really behind
the ouster check it out on the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]